for the the first of these two talks in
this session we're going to have your
own singer of Harvard University
speaking of limitations and
possibilities of optimization for
samples your own adventure coming it's
Bobby so thanks first of all for
organizing this workshop it's really 30
12 pro and it's just always great to be
back in berkeley so what I'm going to
talk about is joint work with Eric
Bolkonsky who is where York is here and
Avion dizzy here ok he probably already
knows what I'm going to talk about but
if you guys have any hard questions you
should find these guys in the and the
after this session ok so what I want to
talk today about is basically what I
think a lot of people in this audience
think about certainly a lot of people in
my home community of algorithmic game
theory think about and this is kind of
this interplay between machine learning
and optimization and I want to start
with this really simple example that
conveys this this kind of intersection
so when I try to decide how to route
from my office at Harvard to ms RMIT
then what I usually do is I I would pick
up my phone and I would look for the
fastest route from the destination to
the source and when I do that what
happens is basically my phone you know
uses calls Google Maps or bing maps in
this example okay and basically does two
things it performs some some kind of
execution of she learning and execution
of optimization okay and here's what I
mean so first of all what happens is
this application is going to try to
learn a model okay and in this case the
model is a directed weighted graph okay
so what happens is it maps the
intersections as nodes okay the the
edges are the roads in between them okay
and then what it does is it fits weights
that describe the congestion from run
run road to another okay let's pray
board and and once that's done okay
comes a an optimization algorithm that
looks as this graph as if this were the
ground truth okay and finds the shortest
path okay and so basically what happened
is we start with data okay about how
people are driving we fitted a model
using what i call machine learning and
then there's optimization to make what I
call a decision okay and what's nice
about this is that basically this kind
of in this case the shortest path
example is pretty robust errors so if we
have small errors on the way that we
learn these weights these congestion
'he's okay it's going to translate into
small errors in the decision okay we may
end up choosing a different path than we
would have had we known the true
congestion 'he's okay but the cop but
the difference in terms of cost is going
to be minimal ok we're going to be small
another example that I want to talk
about is this one that I really like
about influence maximization social
networks so this is where you try to
decide who to you know who dislikes so
that you're maximizing the spread of
information and network okay so let's
zoom in on this a little bit so this is
a this is a this is a network or a graph
where I just didn't draw the edges okay
and the and the individuals that people
are these nodes here in purple okay so
basically what happens in these in this
kind of an example is that we we think
of this the social network has basically
a way to transmission information we we
can fit a model by selecting subset of
individuals we have the edges between
them which are the friendships and then
what's interesting is that we have a
model for the way the people transmit
information from one another okay there
are different models one model is
something like independent cascade where
you're assuming that there is a
probability on each edge to transmit
information okay so saying that this
probability 0.3 means that with
probability 0.3 this node transmits
information to this node so this is
actually a directed model but I'm just
using an undirected graph here just for
simplicity okay and then what happens in
when we have this model what we want to
do is we want to make a decision okay
and the decision that we want to make is
basically
who to select so that we're maximizing
the spread of information and network
okay so think if you have a you know if
you want to advertise in your iphone you
know you have like you have 10 iphones
to give who should you give these 10
iphones through so that you're
maximizing the adoption of iphones in
the network okay so what happens is
again the algorithm looks is this at
this network as if this were the ground
truth it makes a selection so again what
we do is we start with data okay where
we basically learn some model okay and
then once we learn the model we make we
have an optimization step which we
select the individuals that we're going
to give the iphone soon but what's
interesting is when you look at these
kinds of examples then you already see
that really small errors can really
trick the algorithm okay so what do I
mean so let's assume I have some sort of
long path of networks and long chain
okay and let's assume that these people
communicate really well with one another
ok this is contrived but this is going
to convey the point ok so the all
transmit information with probability 1
so when I select this nub the expected
number of nodes influence is going to be
on the order of n ok let's say that n is
the length of the network or sorry the
length of this path now let's say that
have a really good machine learning
algorithm that only has some sort of
epsilon error okay so basically what
happens is it's going to in this case I
want to save a be better have narrow
every edge okay so now when I look at
the influence of this node it is going
to be a constant
so the problem is that if I have these
long chains in the network okay then
this is really going to fool the
algorithm because in the true model
really it should have selected this not
on the left but in the model learn from
data it's going to say well you know
this this node only affects the constant
of nodes so maybe I don't care about it
as much so the ratio between the nodes
are actually influenced the nodes that
are going to be influenced goes to is
going to go to infinity so here I'm just
saying that epsilon is a constant but it
doesn't it can be lower than a cop
that's not quite the same right I mean
your your your ratio there is screaming
out how long its up how far off my
estimate is from the truth that's
different than saying that my actions
are going to be far off from the optimal
action right so I could I could have I
could have and you know I'm all that's
on estimated correctly but still think
so take decisions that are reasonable
okay let's so it's okay good let's hold
on to that thought okay but I'm what I'm
just saying is let's take the naive
algorithm right that it's looking at
this as if this were the ground truth
right then this is what this is the
consequence of that but you're right
maybe that doesn't have to be the case
so let's so this isn't so we should talk
about that right okay good so um okay
sorry so basically what a you know when
we're thinking about when we're thinking
about optimization right from we want to
say optimization from data then we
should really think about what's
happening in this model or kind of
what's happening to the data generating
this model so basically i want to go to
thinking about you know a data is
samples of a function a model is
something that creates a surrogate
function and and then at the end of the
day we want to make a decision which is
an optimization step that makes sense no
so that that's exactly the point right
right so right on both ends we have you
know we have some sort of generative
model right some sort of function that
generates the true data right we can
learn something which is going to be
some sort of approximation of this
function but at the end of the day we
want to make you know decision on you
know evaluated on the true generative
model
okay so the question is right when can
we make reasonable decisions from data
so i want to begin by talking about
saying a few things about optimization
from noisy models to kind of give the
motivation for what i'm going to talk
about which is optimization from samples
so basically i think the roots for this
question were already asked well i guess
back in the you know 70s and 80s but
kind of closer to the things that we're
thinking about this was a so Harvey and
Mel contrary phrase this model of called
PMAC their own ability okay so what's
pmac learnability this is I have a
function and I want to learn that
function and I want to you know and
because i have i'm faced in the learning
scenario you know i'm observing have an
observing sample so i'm going to learn
it somehow approximately correct okay so
i'm going to learn it with some sort of
i can learn with some sort of 1 plus
epsilon error ok so this pmac
learnability right what it says is i
want to basically when I observe
polynomial number of samples I want to
have an algorithm to generate some sort
of surrogate function so that with some
you know constant probability the what i
have is i have a function that
approximates the true function well now
this is a just a natural generalization
to the famous pack model okay and we can
think we can use this kind of thinking
right to to say what does it mean that a
function or a model is learnable and
basically you know their broad classes
of functions that are what's called pmac
learnable may be under some
distributional assumptions okay and
obviously some assumptions about the
classes of function that we can learn
but this is something that that we
understand reasonably well so the
question is you know now that we have
this notion of pee Mak learnability can
we optimize functions with from data
so we can do is we can think about what
we call an epsilon erroneous Oracle and
when you can ask suppose that you have
an epsilon erroneous Oracle right
meaning that instead of a true function
you just have an epsilon approximation
of this function everywhere does that
mean that you were going to be able to
optimize your function so here the
answer is no you can show that very
simple submodular functions okay that
are almost additive just a sec okay when
you have these epsilon errors that are
you know very small constants or even
things r sub constant you will not be
able to get any reasonable approximation
for maximizing the function under
carnality constraints there is a
question
that's right it's stronger right it's
stronger because right because you we
want to ask well because it's a lower
bound right so you want to say I have
these fab these stronger assumptions am
i able to am able to optimize the
function and the answer is no even if I
have these stronger jumps in assumptions
I cannot in general optimize these
functions yeah mommy I wanted to express
the hardness of approximation as a
function of the cardinality constraint
rather than the size of the universe is
it came to the one-half or does it
become almost linear in yeah so here the
usual suspect right is like hey is
square root of n but this will also
happen with you know like any yeah yeah
without you know doesn't have to be
square root of n obviously you can be
all over not sure it can be logged in
but okay but in general this is right
this is you have this end of Proxima
bility so okay but but this assumes that
the errors are somewhat adversarial so
you can ask what happens with noise and
a natural definition of noise is one
where instead of having an adversary
choose the arrow you have this error
being generated by some sort of
distribution and in this case what you
can show is basically optimal guarantees
for this problem of optimization under
corn aldi constraint so this is actually
a good point to pause and say that
everything that I'm talking about is
combinatorial functions today but pretty
much everything that I'm everything that
I'm saying has its natural analog and
convex optimization okay some things
usually what happens is that things are
kind of more technically interesting and
the you know in the realm of coming to
our optimization okay but but for
example what I just said about lower
bounds for 40 newest Oracle's this also
applies for convex functions and this
result is easy for continued to show for
convex functions but somewhat difficult
for some modular functions yeah
can you just say but it's a condition on
the distribution be okay right so
different conditions will give you
different things if you want for now you
can just assume that the distribution is
bounded otherwise you can have you could
we can essentially you can define this
somewhat artificial class of
distributions but this but is still to
start this class of distributions kind
of most classes of distributions that
you think about will be in this
distribution in this result will hold my
idea with a different sets s yeah and
everything at everything is iid you can
show these nasty lower bounds for
correlated distributions you know
basically the adversarial result is for
you know correlate distribution as you
can show like you can show other lower
bounds for like simple correlated
distributions basically this is kind of
what we can we can cone I think we can
hope to get ya is your approximation
algorithm agnostic to the shape of the
noise does the album designer need to
know the distribution d when no yeah
it's agnostic to the same noise as any
to know the distribution the reason why
is it a ting is because there's an issue
of how many samples there's a smoothing
in part and then there is a question of
like how many samples needs to do for
smoothing so you can define if the
distributor's is bounded and you know
you're fine okay so but you know some
complexity parameter of the distribution
yes you have an upper bound on that
parameter you go yes okay but this is
not what I want to talk about okay I
mean I I do and don't write so what I
want to do is I want to kind of present
this as motivation for for what I really
want to talk about okay so what's so why
why am I telling you this well I'm
telling you this because you're looking
at you know we have this we have
functions we know that they're learnable
right and now we're asking can we do
something from these functions that are
learnable from data and you know then we
at this point we sort of its a mix you
know we it's a bit we know that if you
know if the errors are adversarial then
the answer is no but maybe these are not
adversarial maybe they fall into this
category right you know which is which
is good wicked which we can optimize
them
right so and maybe your algorithm and
maybe it's the case that your algorithm
you know the errors don't fall into this
category but they you know but maybe
there's a different learning algorithm
where the errors would fall into this
category so instead of these you know
instead of asking all this what we need
to do is we need to basically just lose
the middleman we need to look at data
and see if we can make a decision does
that make sense we need to look at the
input of the week as algorithm designers
we basically need to look at the input
of the machine learning algorithm as if
as if that's our input okay and from
that babe just be able to design our
approximation algorithm okay so this is
optimization from samples so now you can
ask any questions all right so what's
the model really I don't think that
there is much of a model here but it's
what I said there's you know basically
there's a put to the machine learning
algorithm and you're trying to optimize
it so but you know okay nevertheless you
see you see a distribution over sets and
their function values and your objective
is to make a decision which is to
maximize your function under some
constraint okay and everything that I'm
going to talk about is just going to be
cardinality constraint you can think of
more complicated constraints like may
Troi constraints and other things but
for the purpose of this talk everything
is just going to be carnality
constraints okay and now what are we
going to assume for making this problem
interesting the first thing we're going
to assume is the observations are
feasible if they're not feasible it's
really easy to show these a possibility
results you're you know all your samples
are coming from you know sets of size
one and you're now asked to optimize
sets of sighs you know square root of n
right and you know you have a square
root of n lower bound you know that's
not surprised
so we're going to assume that
distributions are over feasible sets the
second thing that we're going to assume
is that this function is statistically
learnable we can talk about functions
are pack learnable or pee Mak learnable
ok and the reason is because intuitively
we think that you know we should be able
to find positive results in places where
the functions are somewhat learnable ok
and finally this is a no-brainer the
function should be optimized abul
because if it's not optimized abaut
optimizing belen the sense that if
there's in the value oracle model right
if you can you should be able to query
us if you query a said get the and get
the function value right then in
polynomial you know and then that takes
you like you know well in polynomial
time then basically in polynomial time
you should be able to optimize your
function right because somewhat if if
that doesn't happen then you shouldn't
be able to you know expect to optimize
your function when you have less
information and the question is whether
we can optimize things from samples so
the main result is then the answer is no
we show that their functions that are
heavily used in practice that are
learnable and optimized about but to
which there is no constant factor
approximation
and what I want to do is I want to talk
about this impossibility result i'll
give you like this very high-level
technical overview and then i'll talk a
little bit about possibility results and
just conclude okay so this is maybe a
good time to take questions over the
model or okay i didn't understand the
assumption about the distribution over
SI if you if you only assume that it's
supported on the set of on the
collection of feasible sets it sounds
like you could if the feasible sets are
all sets of cardinality from one up
decay I could still give you a
distribution supported on Singleton's
not any distribution there are
distributions over Singleton's so the
question is what is our notion of
universality I'd like for the lower
bound right so one ocean is to say for
all distributions I can show you that
you're naughty there's no distribution
under which you're going to be able to
optimize from samples right which is
what we're showing no feasible
distributions or right we can say we can
talk about or we can kind of look at the
orthogonal or we can look at being kind
of like the the orthogonal direction
which is going to add which is going to
ask to remove this assumption about
observations being feasible right and
then we would need to for the low ground
we just need to show that there exists
the distribution right for which we have
been a possibility results and both
things are you know and the result holds
for both like both perspectives if that
makes sense
now i think i think what is asking is if
you're trying to optimize a function of
K and all your samples of size 1 yes so
then there is a trivial right so then
there is a travel you know then there is
a trivial lower bound right wait let me
let me check brake my question in a much
more obtuse way assumption number one
says that a distribution colon equals a
set so my type checker rejects your
slide because the left hand side has the
type probability distribution and the
right hand side is the type of set is
are you just sorry is d the uniform
distribution over sorry d is it well D
is a district if for simplicity for
simplicity yes okay but in general no it
can be any any distribution any
distribution over feasible solutions Oh
your lower bound has a for all quantum
yes a brand yet okay thanks ok sorry
this is this is not a good way to ride
this support specified you have like a
black box which has this distribution
and it denied it takes off a draw sample
comment and um so I'm assuming that i'm
assuming that somebody generates these
samples right from you know and all my
assumption is that these samples are
coming from a distribution but i don't
know what that distribution is
necessarily
no okay good question no so if i could
adaptively sample then i would be in a
value query model where i know that i'm
able to optimize the wide range of
functions okay so what's kind of what
goes into showing this an approximate
ility of coverage functions which is the
class of functions that we show the
lower bound for okay so first of all I
should define what a coverage function
is okay so i drew this little picture
here and basically a coverage function
is when you have a elements in some sort
of universe and you have sets to cover
these elements the coverage function is
basically when you take a union of these
sets and you look at their their
carnality then that's the that's the
covers function okay and coverage
functions are nice they're heavily used
in keene learning data mining mechanism
design and other things so the influence
maximization example that I gave is
actually a more basically a
generalization of a corporate function
we know that the greedy algorithm gives
you one gives us a 1-1 of ria proxim a
shin and we know that that's optimal and
we know that their pee Mak learnable so
vitally here with Pradesh qatari showed
that there p Makka learnable with an
efficient algorithm when we have uniform
distributions or product distributions
and Bobby with ashwin astron bundanoon
Dhiru shahar division ski who foo k is
for Bobby Kleinberg Anna's for Nissan
and ours for Tim roughgarden here she'll
head was impressive showed that
so that covers functions basically our
pee Mak burnable within any factor Y
minus epsilon but without giving an
algorithm but at least information
theoretically we know that their you
know their pee Mak variable and also
there are somewhat canonical examples of
submodular functions so if you kind of
want to think about what is wasn't what
is a nice function that kind of
describes the what makes you know the
intricacies of some modular functions
then coverage functions are aid you have
other nice properties that maybe I'll
talk about later okay right so our lower
bound says that there's no constant
factor approximation for basically
optimizing a coverage functions from
samples for any any distribution of over
feasible sense ok so maybe I should have
had that slide earlier right and some
like the implications of this right are
that essentially from any real world you
know problems that we care about in the
real world and of their real-world
problems that their problems that we
claim to care about in the real world we
know that there's basically no provable
guarantees right it may be that we're
learning functions and then we know how
to optimize them but essentially you
know we could argue whether whether it's
meaningful to do that right it says also
that basically the fact that we have
something that's learnable and
approximate bowl doesn't necessarily
imply that it's optimized about from
samples okay and or the way that I tell
this to my mom is that basically
predictions can be easy and decisions
can be hard okay all right so how do we
show an approximate ility question
mullings it still seems to be that you
could be in this situation the for any
distribution there is some part of the
domain over which you just don't learn
anything and therefore
you will not be able to optimize for
some functions Oh what if once you fix
the distribution you can pick a function
but what you won't see anything sort of
useful to be able to optimize it one
sort of but that I mean in some sense
since you have already the distribution
you could say some things are more
natural than others maybe all you care
is to be better than like one minus some
alpha fraction of all the points of view
you observe you don't want to find the
true maximum but you want to be better
than anything that could it like some
sort of large fraction that you have a
lot of things that you are absorb of
course if you just do nol put you could
do it in polynomial time but maybe you
could do something better than that what
I mean is is because some inputs are
more natural than others because you
have you assume that they exist a
distribution we try to define
maximization relative to the
distribution too yes maybe I'll talk
about that in the end but the problem
with notions like that I think that's a
very good question so if I understand
your question correctly you're asking
well i'm going to paraphrase here okay
in learning theory right we learned that
there's no reason you know there's no
way that we should be able to you know
learn a function on a different
distribution you know then what we've
seen so why would this make any sense
for optimization is that roughly okay so
tell me so here are two things that will
not say about that I think I think
that's a very good question and we're
certainly thinking about this right so
so two things are well one of the things
is because for you know when when you
enter this you when you enter this world
as somebody comes from optimization then
you don't care about what people learned
about learning theory right in the sense
that you want to optimize the function
right that's what you you know and that
that's what you want to do right and
with influence maximization right like
you know think about like how to
optimize the function so
you know what does it mean that I know
you know what does it mean that why do I
care now that functions are so modular
if you know if if there's no way that I
can actually optimize them from you know
from from the David icing but the but
the but here's a but the more technical
answer is that we could look at notions
that alternative notions of optimization
from samples where we're looking at
we're looking at basically we're
learning a distribution you know we're
learning a function over one
distribution that we want to optimize
over another well and then we and then
we basically want to kind of get a good
average approximation over that same
distribution we do that then basically
we kind of what we're looking at we're
looking at these basically we're looking
at properties of distributions we're
looking at essentially how well we can
approximate the the maximum from a
distribution does that make sense like
we can talk about this more offline or
at the end but but basically you can you
can you can basically kind of find you
can define like a function which is the
constant function and that that's
basically going to be good enough for
for optimizing over for data set drawn
from the same distribution and one could
argue that maybe the constant function
is not something very meaningful to
optimize over but you can talk about
them okay but sticking to this notion of
optimization from samples so what goes
into why should you know how do we show
a lower bound right so the first
question that you should ask yourself is
like why should there be a little round
right if we think about you know you
standard lower bounds in optimization
there's the value query model right and
basically the way that we show lower
bounds in this valley for your model is
we construct two functions here it's
going to be F and H and basically H is
going to kind of grow a little bit and
then it's going to level off and F is
just going to be a function that
continues on growing and essentially
what happens is that we say look
especially many queries these these
functions
are going to be the same right so it's
going to be hard to distinguish between
them and then we get this gap between
them and in the valley query model the
gap is 1-1 of re so what what has
happened what's different in
optimization from samples so one thing
is you want to create these exactly this
kind of effect but so that exponentially
many samples now are going to fall into
this region where things look exactly
the same right and then you have one
function that levels off and then
another function that continues on
growing but now this gap has to grow
from 1 minus 1 over e to enter the
should be one and to the minus 3rd okay
so now the gap needs to be huge so
somehow the fact that we're looking at
samples right makes this makes us this
gap grow by a lot the second thing is
for coverage functions you can you just
don't have this property that they level
off so nicely so for coverage functions
what happens is that the the functions
have some sort of curvature my out of
timer when it's out of time or you have
a couple minutes to go have a components
to go okay good yeah okay so now the
approximation gap is and to the way
don't have like 15 more minutes mommy
this one isn't that like the nightmare
of of the audience schedule it's Maya's
room by mistake okay every time slot by
mistake okay okay good all right so i'll
give you the extended version role have
ya wrong decision yeah it's it's not an
online algorithm you decide in the
beginning and you know you lost okay so
now we need to show that the
approximation gap is just going to
decrease a little bit okay um I'll make
you a deal 10 minutes I have no
bargaining position okay okay um so so
to show this lower bound okay so okay so
let me just give you five slides on the
on how to show this lower bound on what
goes into this all right so this lower
bound is in a class of class of
corporate functions okay they're defined
by basically there is a partition here
t0 TM it's a partition of the ground set
and now these functions are defined
based on the partition and they're
basically sums of coverage functions
which we call good functions that have
high value and bad functions that have
low value which is they should be
surprised
so what we do is basically the first
thing we do is we reduce this question
of optimization from samples to
properties on these good and bad
functions so now what we do is we say
okay if you have good and bad functions
that respect these three properties then
we give you a lower bound ok so then
what we need to do is we need to define
these good and bad functions that have
these properties ok so to do that
there's a what we do is we define these
class of primitives these are particular
coverage functions that have these nice
properties that we prove in a third part
and then we get a lower bound for
coverage functions with when
distributions are drawn from when the
samples are drawn from the uniform
distribution and when the universe is
exponentially large so we then we just
remove these two assumptions ok so what
are these properties that the good and
bad functions need to respect so they
have three properties basically they
need to be identical on small sets like
a shot and like I show them the drawing
there needs to be this large gap you
know in larger sense and finally when we
need to have is we need to have this
curvature property of the good function
ok
so the first thing we show is we show
theorem that says okay if you have good
and bad functions that have these three
properties then we can give you lower
bound as a function of these properties
so how do we build these good and bad
functions to have these properties so
what we do is we have this class of
primitive these coverage functions that
respect the identical and small sets
they have this alpha gap and large sets
and then they have this curvature
property for thee for the large sets so
how do we how do we think about this so
what we do is we define these good and
bad functions in terms of these
primitives that I haven't told you what
they are and I'm not going to tell you
what they are I'll just kind of sketch
them out too okay but what we do is we
kind of we say we put this in some sort
of as a system of linear equations where
every column here is the function values
four sets of size 1 through L okay these
functions are symmetric and then both
the good and the bad functions are
defined you bay as convex combinations
of these of these coverage functions and
the good function also is defined in
terms of this Y so to get this property
of being identical in small sets what we
do is we basically show that okay that
when we when we put these coverage
functions in this matrix form then this
matrix is invertible okay then we have
this property of being identical in
small sets and then we show that these
when we show that that these multipliers
are bounded then we can show this
curvature property so what it ends up
boiling down to is how do we construct
these special primitives these special
coverage functions that have all these
nice properties so I'm going to let you
look at the paper okay but basically
what they are is we define them in terms
of the binomial distribution okay and
then to show that the matrix is
invertible we give some sort of
polynomial interpretations of these from
shins and then we show that the
coefficients are bounded use ha demands
inequality okay this is kind of the
these are the technical details that I'm
kind of putting under the table then
they're finally they're just like two
more steps okay we need to kind of make
these coverage instead of having a
special universe we have they end up
having compact representation so we
basically do this with like hey why's
independence so again this is kind of a
more technical aspect so you can look at
that in the paper and then finally we go
from from having everything to find on a
just on a uniform distributions to we
can show this this holds for any
feasible distribution over feasible
sense putting all this together we get
the we get a lower bound you gather for
any any distribution coverage functions
cannot be optimized from samples the
approximation in a bit approximate ease
are n to the minus one-fourth when we
have exponential size representation of
universe and what we have compact
nervous which is polynomial size then we
just have something that's non constant
so this result is you know also applies
to the case where you actually know
exactly what the sets are okay but you
just don't know the weights okay and
basically this is what I told Bobby
earlier you can kind of alternate
between saying but if you don't want
this kind of result / feasible solutions
you can have you can define you can have
like you can have this in approximately
result for uniform distributions over
any any sense okay so in general for we
can for for other classes of functions
like XOS we can show tight bounds and
the upper bound we have an upper bound
of and to the minus one-third and that
applies to any similar function
okay so this is all the bad news so now
here are some good news so I'm going to
talk about some positive results
everything that I'm going to talk about
is for the uniform distributions so for
added two functions which is a special
case of coverage functions you can show
that they're optimized abul for samples
how there's an algorithm that you can
basically use to recover the function
value exactly okay after pulling them in
many samples and then you're out you can
optimize the function so basically what
happens is that add two functions are
what we call recoverable right you can
recover the function value with an
arbitrary precision so a natural
question is whether optimization from
samples requires the function to be
recoverable and the answer is no because
you can look at unit demand functions
and you in the van demand functions you
can show these ridiculously simple
examples showing that there is no way in
the world that you'll be able to recover
the function but there's really easy to
optimize from samples ok so this
optimization from samples is a notion
which is you know weaker than
recoverability so is this basically
because you don't need to recover the
function value at points that are very
far away from the max no it's it's even
simpler than that you can just basically
ok so here's the example think of like
half of your elements are you know have
value one happy I'm let's have values
zero you not see random samples of you
know sufficiently you know K elements
right with you know when K is large
enough with a very high probability in
every sample there's going to be like a
large element right so that's it but you
have no way of knowing which of the
elements is the large one which is this
the small
ok so I actually gave a related talk at
CMU last year than a broom asked well
said this probably is not going to apply
for functions that have found a
curvature and I thought that it would
but turns out he was absolutely right so
we can show that if you're special cases
when your function has mounted curvature
meaning that two ative lee it's not far
away from being an additive function ok
where you can bound how far away it your
sub modular function is from being
additive ok so whenever this function
has curvature see there is a kind of
this weird approximation ratio but this
is justified by the fact that it's
actually tight you can show so modular
functions that have this this curvature
and for which there is no algorithm that
can do better so so there's some you
know there's some light at the end of
the top just to conclude okay so okay so
what we saw is in general right when we
have small summation errors that can
lead to tragedies unless we make some
assumptions about what these estimation
errors are right so but in in general in
this case of you know these terms of
vulnerability we don't know what these
errors are so we need to actually look
at what's happening from the you know
from the input of the learning algorithm
I think the moral question is what's the
limitation of you know the optimization
models that we have right we should kind
of know what they are and acknowledge
them and know when we have approval
guarantees and when we don't I think
that a lot of for some of the problems
that I've been thinking about I kind of
know how that identified you know let's
say to put it mildly the cases in which
i don't have provable guarantees okay if
somebody's learning if if I'm optimizing
a function that's being learned from
data but that function is very far away
from you know from reality then doesn't
matter that I know how to give a tight
one minus 1 over e approximation
so you know so basically learning and
sketching frameworks you know where we
have this these errors introducing them
they also have the same kind of
approximate ease and in general these
decisions from data and general don't
have provable guarantees so with that so
how's the picture change if you went to
a model with other team play
approximation rather than keeping to be
one functions between zero and one but
now you won't take an epsilon additive
approximation yeah so that's a good
question is our experience not not by
not not a lot yeah the lower band still
apply so when we look at okay so when we
look at convex optimization we look at
we look at additive approximations and
then and then let your lower bounds
still still apply so yeah so for ok so i
should say what was going on for convex
optimization for convex optimization
it's not it's technically much easier to
show lower bounds for essentially for
piecewise linear functions okay you can
optimize linear functions from samples
but when it's peaceful in your already
you cannot so in terms of looking for
other brighter more optimistic points of
light something likes know
a symmetric semantic function okay yeah
yeah okay that's a very good question
okay so one could look okay so um kind
of let me tell you what our thought
process was first of all you know what
we're looking as we're looking at
constraint optimization and it's nicer
to me you know look at unconstrained
optimization but for non monotone
functions we know that without doing
anything right we can get we can get for
for non amounts of modular functions we
can just by random sampling we can get a
one-fourth approximation right so so
basically it sort of takes the you know
this thing away from an a possibility
results right so we thought well if we'd
show the possibility showing the kind of
like separation with samples you can
only do half but without samples you can
do like one from so kind of like one for
the you know where things will be
dramatic but you're right it could be
that symmetric functions could be like a
natural class of functions to look end
so is it make sense to consider some
sort of maybe in between models like
it's the way I have this picture of my
head is you know you're trying to find
the highest point on the hill and what
you have to work with are the heights of
random points and so it's kind of
challenging if you know the hill could
have a spike somewhere you know and you
didn't didn't see that you know God on
the other hand you are saying it has to
be reasonable in that in the sense that
you have to you it should be that with
value queries you can do something well
so if you can actually climb the hill
you know you should so so on the one
hand you have are allowed fully that the
queries you know and then under you know
so we're going to assume that you have
to at least be able to do well there
because we can't do well they're your
dad then what you're saying is that if
you just get these random samples it's
not enough information what does it make
sense to consider some model in between
where maybe you know I don't know the
model where yeah someday that you can do
a little bit yeah eric has been thinking
kind of more actively than i have about
exactly the same between model where
maybe you can kind of bound the number
of where you can down the number of
adaptive queries that you make maybe so
maybe we can have like hybrid saying
that okay you have a pool of samples and
now you're allowed to make like a small
number of queries maybe maybe there's
something to do there so that's a that's
a really that's a that's a reasonable
model i think in a very question so
alright let's thank you are on again